ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BASE
BECKER OUR ADDRESS BRADFORD
HAVE I GOTTA CORTESE DALLY DODD
DURAZO EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROWTH HERTZBERG WEST SO HER
TADO JONES CAN LONGER LAYERED
LEYVA BLUE MOON MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S MEN. NEWMAN NIELSEN I
TRIED BOTH HAN FORTUNE TINO
RALPH RUBIO SKINNER STERN
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE STEVE WEINER
WELL. MEMBERS OF THE QUORUM IS
PRESENT THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE. WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY CENTER MY CASKEY
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AND WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. BY SENATOR GROWTH. SONORA
CASKEY YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. AS WE
LEAVE FOR WORK FOR THE WEEKEND
LET US PRAY FOR THIS BLESSING
ON ONE ANOTHER. MAY GOD OF
TRANSFORMATION CALL YOU OPENING
YOU TO CONTINUAL RENEWAL MAY A
GOD OF JUSTICE COMFORT YOU
DURING YOU SEE THE WORLD
THROUGH THEIR EYES. MAY GOD OF
ABUNDANCE OF FIRM YOU KNOW
AGING YOU TOWARDS DEEPER
TRUSTS. ME A GOD OF EMBRACES
HOLD YOU SIT IN CIRCLING YOU IN
THE HEARTH OF GOD'S HOME. MAY
GOD OF HOPELESS HOPEFULNESS
BLESS YOU ENCOURAGING YOU WITH
THE FRUITS OF FAITH. MAY GOD OF
WELCOMING INVITE YOU DRAWING
YOU TO THE FULLNESS OF THEIR
EXPRESSION IN U. MA A GOD WHO
IS PRESENT. BE WITH YOU
AWAKENING YOU TO GOD IN ALL
THINGS TO ALL PEOPLE. AND ALL
MOMENTS A MAN. FOR CALLING SO
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SALUTING A
FLAG THAT REPRESENTS FREEDOM
NOT ONLY HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES BUT AROUND THE WORLD. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
HALL. THANK YOU CENTER RIGHT
CASKEY AND SENATOR GROVE. THIS
MORNING MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEAN READ AND
AMEND ITS AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE ON
NOW TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES- WE HAVE A COUPLE
OF FOUR MOTIONS THAT WE WILL BE
TAKING UP RIGHT NOW. PURSUANT
TO A SENATE RULE TWENTY NINE
POINT ONE ZERO D. THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE REFERRED TO RULES
COMMITTEE. ITEM TWENTY FIVE SP
THIRTY FIVE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
SB FORTY EIGHT. ITEM FIFTY ONE
SP SIX FORTY SIX. THERE ARE
FOUR MINUTES AT THE DESK THEY
WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED. ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. SEVEN NINE WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING FILES SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL.
932-229-1231 007-405-1170 THREE
AND RUNNING WILL BE DEEMED
ADOPTED MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS AFTER THAT WE HAVE
SOME UNFINISHED BUSINESS AND-
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING THEY
WERE GONNA BE TAKING UP SEVERAL
DOZEN ITEMS TODAY IF THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE OFF THE FLOOR
CAN COME TO THE FLOOR AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR ALL OF US. AND
MOVING ON TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT CENTER LAYERED WILL
BE PRESENTING THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS ITEM SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN CENTER LAYER PLEASE
OPEN ON ITEM SEVENTEEN. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE I'M
SEVENTEEN IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF JEFFREY MCCUMBER AS
UNDERSECRETARY FOR OPERATIONS.
AT CDC ARE HE BEGAN HIS CAREER
THERE'S A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO. HE
SERVED IN MULTIPLE POSITIONS
INCLUDING AS WARDEN AND MOST
RECENTLY AS UNDERSECRETARY FOR
ADMINISTRATION. HIS APPOINTMENT
WAS APPROVED IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON AUGUST TWENTY
FIFTH I RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR
AN ENVELOPE. THANK YOU CENTER
LAYER ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. MEMBERS
WE STILL HAVE A FEW SENATORS
MISSING WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL CALL ONCE PUT
THE MEASURE ON CALL UNTIL WE
HAVE A FULL HOUSE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA. FIVE ATKINS. I BASE.
BACKER I PORCHES BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM HI CORTEZ E. I.
DALI. DOT HI THERE ALSO I
EGGMAN. BLAZER I CONSOLIDATE
HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG I WAS SO
HYPER TANTO HI JONES. CAN
LONGER. LAYERED I LABOR I THE
MON. HI MIKE WEIR I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON. I TRIED
BOTH. PAM I FORTUNE TINO. I.
ROSS. HI RUBIO I SKINNER HI
STERN. AMBERG HI WHAT CASKEY I
WINNER I WILL KNOW. SINNER
LAYERED MOVES A CALL CENTRE
LAYERED PLEASE- OPEN ON FILE IN
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
FINAL ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF JENNIFER
BARRETTO AS UNDERSECRETARY FOR
ADMINISTRATION AT C. D. C. R.
SHE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE. SERVICES HER
POINT WAS APPROVED IN THE RULES%
COMMITTEE ON AUGUST TWENTY
FIFTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AUDIBLE THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS HI BABES. BACKER HI FOR
JUST. BRADFORD I HAVE A FIVE. I
DALLY GOD I DRAW SO I EGGMAN.
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I GROSS
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
I JONES. CAN LONGER LAYERED I.
LEIVA I THE MON I WIRE I
MELINDA'S MAN. NEWMAN I NIELSEN.
A SHOW BOTH. PAM HI FOURTEEN
TINA I BROUGHT I REVIEW I
SKINNER. STERN AMBERG HI CASKEY
FIVE WINNER I WILL KNOW.
THEY'RE LAYERED MUSICAL NUMBERS
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS-
CONCURRENCE ITEMS WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE UP FIRST ITEM FIFTY
FIVE AND THEN WE'LL MOVE BACK.
TO TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX TWENTY NINE AND
AUNTS AND SO FORTH SO WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO ITEM FIFTY FIVE.
WHICH IS- SENATOR ROTH HE IS
READY SECRETARY PLEASE RE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT OH THREE BY
SENATOR ROTH AN ACT RELATING TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS
CENTER OFF. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THIS BILL THE
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY
SENSIBILITIES BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE IN THE SENATE. A
FEW ASSEMBLY AMNDMENTS ONE
RESTORE HER CUTTING AND OTHER
BEAUTIFICATION SERVICES AS
REGULATED PRACTICES TO CREATE A
HAIRSTYLING LICENSE. THREE
SPECIFIED THAT IMPROVE COURSE
IN BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY.
IS SHOPPING NOT LESS THAN ONE
THOUSAND HOURS RATHER THAN A
FIRM ONE THOUSAND HOURS IN THE
PREVIOUS VERSION OF THE BILL.
AND MAKES OTHER VARIOUS
CLARIFYING CHANGES RESPECTIVELY
AS ZERO VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
ROBIN DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THIS SIDE OF MEMBERS. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE RETURN
OUR CALL THE WORLD PLEASE. ALAN
I ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I FACE
HI BACKER. HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD. I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ V. I. DALLY. DOT HI
TORONTO HI AIKMAN. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE. HERTZBERG
I WAS SO HI HER TADO HI JONES
HI I CAN LONGER. LAYERED I
LABOR I THE MON REQUIRE FIVE
MELINDA'S MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON
I ASSURE BOTH HI PAM I POURED
INTO YOU KNOW HI RALPH I RUBIO
HI SKINNER I STERN AMBERG HI
WHAT CASKEY I WINNER. I WILL
KNOW. SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON A
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE CEST
SENATOR BRADFORD. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
BRADFORD AN ACT RELATING TO
WORKERS COMPENSATION CENTER
BRADFORD THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AS V. SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE THIS BILL SIMPLY
STATES THATONE'S GENDER RACE
OR OTHER FACTORS SHOULD NOT BE
USED TO DENY ONES- OR REDUCE
ONE'S WORKERS COMPENSATION-
BENEFITS THE SYSTEM TO TURKEY
FACTORS HAVE BEEN USED OVER THE
YEARS AND WERE ASKING THAT
THEY- ARE NO LONGER BEING
CONSIDERED. AND THE SAME LIMITS
SIMPLY NARROW THE BUILD DOWN
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI ADKINS I BASE I BACKER HI
FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD I COME
BY ADAM HI CORTESE HI DOLLY.
GOD HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN FIVE
GLAZER. I CONSOLIDATE HIGH
GROWTH HI KURTZ BERG HI WESTERN
HI- HER TADO FIVE JONES I CAN
LONGER. LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE
MOON. CLICK WIRE I MELINDA'S I
MIN I NEWMAN I NELSON I HAVE A
BOOK I CAN. HI FOURTEEN TINO HI
RALPH I REVIEW FIVE SKINNER HI
STERN I'M BERG I LIKE HOW SKI
FIVE WINNER I WILL. HI CENTER
MOVES A CALL MOVING ON TO FILE
IN TWENTY FOUR. WHICH IS
SENATOR RUBIO. OKAY SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT
RELATING TO DISORDERLY CONDUCT.
SENATOR RUBIO LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE I RISE
TODAY 2% S. B. TWENTY THREE THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS REDUCE THE
OVERALL LIMIT OF WHEN CRIMES OF
REVENGE PORN CAN BE PROSECUTED
FOR NO MORE FROM SIX YEARS TO
FOUR YEARS AT THREE TWENTY
THREE RECEIVE NO NO VOTES IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND WILL
STRENGTHEN PROTECTIONS FOR
VICTIMS OF REVENGE PORN AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIFLE. THANK YOU. MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. YES SEEING NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FACE I
BACKER I PORCHES HI BRADFORD I
COME BY IT OKAY I CORTEZ V. I.
DALLY. DOT I TORONTO BY ADMIN
HI BLAZER I CONSOLIDATE HIGH
GROWTH. HI HURTS BERG I WEAR SO
I HER TADO. HURTADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER. LAYERED HI THE MON.
HI FLAVA I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S
FIVE MEN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN HI
A SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM I
FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT. HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN NUMBER
I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL
HI SENATOR MOVE THE CALL
MEMBERS MOVING ON FILE IN
TWENTY SIX. WE HAVE SENATOR
ALAN. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR ALLEN AN ACT RELATING
TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
SENATOR ALAN YES MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS BILL GRANTS
EXPEDITED SEQUEL A JUDICIAL
REVIEW FOR TRANSFORMATIVE
ENVIRONMENTALLY BENEFICIAL
TRANSIT PROJECTS CERTAINLY
MA'AM IT'S NEAR THE BILL SO AS
TO IMPACT JUST SEVEN GREEN
TRANSIT PROJECTS NOW ACCOUNTING
EXTEND THE TIME. OF THE REVIEW.
THE BILL RECEIVED BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WHEN I LEFT
THE SENATE AND- WHEN IT WAS
PASSED BY THE ASSEMBLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR COMP
YOUR YOUR CONCURRENCE IN THE
SENTIMENTS. SOME OF THEM IT'S-
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ADKINS HI BABES HI
BACKER. FIVE PORCHES ARE YOU
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM ARE YOU
PROTESTING I DALLY. DOT HI
TORONTO HI ADMIN I. LASER I
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE. HURTS BERG.
I WEAR SO. I HER TADO I JOAN.
CAN LONGER. LET I LABOR I THE
MON WHY HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. CONTROL OF
BOTH. I CAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO.
I. ROSS I RUBIO I SKINNER HI
STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER. I WILL. SENATOR MOVES A
CALL MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FILE
AND I'M TWENTY NINE SENATOR
WIENER. SECRETARY PLEASE RE
SENATE BILL ONE TEN VICE
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO MEDICAL CENTER WITH I THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT CALLING SIXTY
ONE TEN IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
BY THIS LEGISLATION-
AUTHORIZES- CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT FINANCIAL INCENTIVES.
TO HELP PEOPLE- GET SOBER AND
STAY SOBER PARTICULARLY FOR
MATH AND OTHER STIMULANTS- THIS
BILL. HAS RECEIVED OVERWHELMING
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES BECAUSE METH ADDICTION-
DOESN'T KNOW THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN RED AND BLUE OR RURAL
AND URBAN ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SUFFERING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU CENTER WINNER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I ACTIONS I FACE I BACKER. I
PORCHES I BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM I PROTESTING HI DALI DIED.
I TORONTO I EXAMINED EYE LASER
I CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH HIGH
HURTS BERG I WAS SO I- TADO. HI
JONES I CAN LONGER LAYERED I
BELIEVE I. HI THE MON I WIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN I. OTERO A BUG HI PAM I
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH. I RUBIO
I SKINNER I STERN NUMBER NINE
FIVE WHAT KIND OF SKI I WINNER
I WILL HI. SENATOR MOVE THE
CALL MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON A FILE IN AND THIRTY
FOLLOWED BY THIRTY ONE THIRTY
THREE THIRTY FIVE AND SEVERAL
MORE LET'S GO IT'S THE ITEM
FILE IN AND THIRTY CENTER
ARCHULETA. SECRETARY PLEASE
REACH. IN ABOUT TWO FORTY FOUR.
AGENCIES LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL THE DEPARTMENT
OF TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL THE
WASTE INDUSTRY AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DEVELOP
PROTOCOLS FOR PROPER MANAGEMENT
OF DISPOSAL OF LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
REMOVED THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
CAL FIRE TO DEVELOP TRAINING
ADDITION TO DEVELOPING
PROTOCOLS THIS BILL HAD
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY AFTER
I BOUGHT THANK YOU ST ARCHULETA
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ADKINS. HI
BABES. HI BECKER I PORCHES HI
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ V. I. DALLY DOT. HI
TORONTO I ADMIN HI LASER EYE
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROWTH. HI
HURTS BERG I WISH SO. HI HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER
LAYERED HI LABOUR I THE MON I
WIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN
I NELSON. I A SHOW BOTH HI PAM
I FORTUNE TINO I BROUGHT. I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN I'M
BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I
WILL. HI SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS MOVING ON THE FINAL
ITEM THIRTY ONE SENATOR BURGESS
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE OH THREE BY SENATOR
FORGES AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. CENTER
BOARDS MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT SENAE BILL THREE OH
THREE WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL AND-
REFORMING IN NATURE- THAT'S
THREE THREE THREE WOULD EXTEND
THE TIME ALLOWED FOR THOSE
WHOSE PROPERTY WAS DAMAGED OR
DESTROYED BY A DISASTER.
TRANSFER THEIR ASE YEAR VALUE
TO A REPLACEMENT PROPERTY.
CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF
WILDFIRES OVER THE YEARS THAT
HAVE DESTROYED MANY HOMES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THIS IS
LEFT COUNTLESS RESIDENTS
DISPLACED AND IN A FIGHT TO
MEET THE FIVE YEAR DEADLINE
ALLOWED TO ACQUIRE. OR
CONSTRUCT A REPLACEMENT
PROPERTY IN THE SAME COUNTY CAN
QUALIFY FOR A TRANSFER OF THEIR
BASE YOUR VALUE. AT A TIME WHEN
THESE DISPLACED RESIDENTS WERE
BEGINNING TO PUT THEIR LIVES
BACK TOGETHER FOLLOWING THESE
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES. COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HIT BRINGING
CRITICAL SECTORS OF GOVERNMENT
IN THE ECONOMY TO A GRINDING
HALT. DUE TO DELAYS AS A RESULT
OF THE PANDEMIC SOME RESIDENTS
WERE UNABLE TO MEET OUR
DEADLINE OF REPLACING OR
REBUILDING. SP THREE OH THREE
WOULD RELIEVE SOME OF THE
PRESSURE PUT ON THESE RESIDENTS
BY EXTENDING THE DEADLINE BY
TWO YEARS. TO ALLOW ADDITIONAL
TIME TO REBUILD OR ACQUIRE A
REPLACEMENT PROPERTY. FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR I. VOTE COLLEAGUES ON SP
THREE OH THREE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BARGES MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FACE I
BACKER HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I COME BY IT- HI
CORTEZ C. I. DALI DOG. I DRAW
SO HI EGGMAN. GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH. HI
HURTS BERG I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER
LAYERED. I LLEVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN I NELSON I A TELEPHONE I
CAN. HI FORTUNE TINO HI ROB I.
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN- BERG I
WAKE OUT SKI I WINNER I WILL.
HI SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO FILE AND THIRTY
THREE CENTER PANEL SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTY NINE BY SENATOR PAN AN
ACT RELATING TO FLOOD CONTROL
CENTER PANEL THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS ARE RICE TO
BRING USP THREE SIXTY NINE
WHICH SECOND CURRENCY SIMPLY
MINUTES MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES
AND HOW LOCAL STATE FEDERAL
WATER AGENCIES WORK TOGETHER TO
STRENGTHEN COORDINATION FOR
FUTURE FLOOD PROTECTION
PROJECTS ESPECIALLY ASPIRIN I
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
SIR PEN MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE. HI BECKER. HI
FORGES I BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI QUARTET THE- HI DAWALY
DODD I DRAW SO I EXAMINED EYE
LASER EYE GONZALEZ I GROW HI
HURTS BERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. I MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A TOTAL OF
BOTH I PAN HI PORTS AND TINA I
BROUGHT I REVIEW I SKINNER. I
STERN NUMBER HI WE HAVE SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HI CENTER MOVES
A CALL MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON A
FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE FOLLOWED
BY. THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
THIRTY NINE FILE IN THIRTY FIVE
A SENATOR GLAZIER. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FOUR
FORTY SIX BY SENATOR GLAZER AN
ACT RELATING TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE SENTENCING THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS JUST
BEFORE FOUR SIX WOULD CLEAR
HURDLES THAT ARE NOW IN PLACE
FOR THE WRONGLY CONVICTED TO BE
COMPENSATED FOR TIME THEY SPENT
UNJUSTLY IMPRISONED THE BILLS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AFTER CO
AUTHORS READ IT IN THE ASSEMBLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU SIR GLAZER ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BASE HI
BACKER. HI PORCHES FIVE
BRADFORDI COME BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ V. I. DALI. GOD HI DRAW
SO I EXAMINED EYE PLEASER. HI
GONZALEZ HI GROSS HI HURTS BERG
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES
I CAN LONGER WHERE DO I LLEVA
HI THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEN HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF THE- I TEN
I. FORTUNE TINO HI ROB I RUBIO.
I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG HI WE
CASKEY I WINNER I WILL HI
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
MOVING ON THE FINAL ITEM THIRTY
SEVEN SENATOR ROSS. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SIX
TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR ROTH AN
ACT RELATING TO IDENTIFICATION
CARDS CENTER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THIS BILL BACK ON
CONCURRENCE EXPANDS ACCESS FOR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS TO
RECEIVE A CALIFORNIA DEDICATION
KURT CAL ID. AND ESTABLISHES A
PATHWAY FOR ELIGIBLE
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS TO
RENEW I SAY RENEW CALIFORNIA
DRIVER'S LICENSE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY DIRECT
CDCR TO FACILITATE THE PROCESS
BETWEEN INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND AGENCIES
HOLDING DOCUMENTS REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE A CAL ID APPLICATION.
TWO AMENDMENTS ELIMINATE THE
OUTSTANDING FEE PROVISION IN
THE PRIOR VERSION OF THE BILL
AND AUTHORIZES CDCR AND DMV TO
ISSUE RENEWED DRIVER'S LICENSES
IN LIEU OF CALIFORNIA ID'S. IF
AN INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL
MEETS THE EXISTING RENEW BY
MAIL ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA AND
IF THEY'RE DRIVING PRIVILEGE
WAS VALID WITHIN THE PRIOR TEN
YEARS. THE BILLS RECEIVE NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU SERRA
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I ADKINS I FACE I BACKER HI
FORGES BY BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI CORTESE HI DAWALY DODD.
HI TORONTO HI EXAMINED EYE
LASER EYE GONZALEZ HI GROSS I
HURTS BERG I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER
AIRED I LABOR. HI THE MOMENT I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S FIVE MIN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A TRAIL OF
BOTH I PAN. I FORTINO HI RALPH
I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
AMBERG HI HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HI SENATOR MOVES
A CALL MEMBERS WERE TO SKIP
THIRTY EIGHT AND GO TO THIRTY
NINE. SENATOR SKINNER. ISRAELI
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
SKINNER AN ACT RELATING TO AIR
POLLUTION CENTER SKINNER. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS ASKING
TWENTY SEVEN IS BACK ON CONCERT
CURRENTS THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. DELAYED THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND ADDED FUEL REDUCTION
AND PRESCRIBED FIRE TO DEFINE-
NATURAL WORKING LANDS CARBON
SEQUESTRATION WITH THAT I
ANSWER I DON'T. THINK USERS GET
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. I'M FINE I'M THIRTY
NINE. SEEING NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI ASKINS I BASE. I
BETTER I FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD
I COME BY ADAM I COURTESY HI
DOLLY. GOD FIVE THEY'RE AWESOME
HI EXAMINED EYE LASER EYE
GONZALEZ HI GROSS I HEARD
SPURRED I WENT SO. I HER TADO
HI JONES NO CAN LONGER LAYERED
I LLEVA I THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A CHOKE HI CAN I
FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT I RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL
NOW. SENATOR MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS MOVING ON A FILE AND
I'M FORTY FOR ME FOLLOWED BY
414-024-0340 FOUR THE FILE ITEM
FORTY IS- SENATE REPORT TEEN-
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL TWO TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR
FORTUNE TINO AND ACT RELATING
TO PEOPLE INSTRUCTION CENTER
POINT YOU KNOW. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS ASKED ME TO
FORCE BACK ON CONCURRENCE WITH
THE MEMON SAID INSURE OUR
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
RECEIVE CRUCIAL MENTAL HEALTH
EDUCATION IN SCHOOLS THAT OFFER
ONE OR FOUR POINT ONE OR MORE
COURSES IN HEALTH EDUCATION THE
MEMBERS ALSO REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DEVELOP A PLAN BY
JANUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
FOUR TO EXPAND MENTAL HEALTH
INSTRUCTION IN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPHONE. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT YOU KNOW MEMBERS NEED
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE SECOND YES WE
HAVE ONE SENATOR RUBIO. REALLY
GOOD I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR I'M A PROUD
CO AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE AND
ITS REALLY NEEDED IN OUR SCHOOL
SO WITH THAT I ALSO ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT
KINS I BASE I BECKER. HI FOR
JUST FIVE BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI COURTESY HI DALI DIED.
HI TORONTO I EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH FIVE HERZ
BERG I WAS SO. I HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER. LAYERED I
LABOR. HI THE MON HI WIRE. HI
MELINDA'S I MAN I. NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF BOTH I PAM
I FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH HI
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I STERN
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI FIVE
WINNER I WILL HI. IN ORDER TO
MOVE THE CALL MEMBERS MOVING ON
A FILEIN FORTY ONE SINNER MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR
MAN AN ACT RELATING TO FIREARMS
CENTERMAN THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- SP TWO SIXTY FOUR
WOULD AS ORIGINALLY DRAFTED
WOULD HAVE BANNED THE SALE OF
GUNS FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION
AND FIREARM PRECURSOR PARTS. BY
ANY STATE ON PROPERTY HI IN THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS A. WAS
AMENDED TO BE LIMITED TO THE
THIRTY SECOND. DISTRICT
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATION ALSO
pAND EVENT CENTER- THIS BILL IS
NOW VERY DISTRICT SPECIFIC-
WE'RE FACING A GUN VIOLENCE
EPIDEMIC AND I WILL SAY. THAT
WHILE THIS BILL WILL MAKE
ORANGE COUNTY FAMILY SAFER- I
AM DISAPPOINTED THAT IT DOESN'T
GO FAR ENOUGH BUT I DO
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SIR MEN MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
AND I'M FORTY ONE. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I FACE NO BACKER HI
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI PROTESTING HI DOLLY.
GOD I DRAW SO I HAVEN I LASER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROSS NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I HER TADO.
JONES NO CAN WATER LAYERED I
LABOR I THE MON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. NO A TROUBLED. NO PAN
I FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH. RUBIO
I SKINNER FIVE STERN BERGER I
LIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL
NOW. CINEMAS A CALL MEMBERS
MOVING THE FILE AND FORTY TWO
CENTER WINNER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THREE
FOURTEEN BY SENATOR WIENER AN
ACT RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE AT SIX THIRTY
MEDIALLY. CENTER WINNER THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
ISSUED THREE FOURTEEN AS
FACULTY CURRENTS OF THIS WILL
EXTEND THE EXTREMELY POPULAR-
OUTDOOR DINING- EXPANSIONS. FOR
ALCOHOL SERVICE THAT WAS- AN
ACTOR BY THE GOVERNOR AS PART
OF THE PANDEMIC WE WANT TO MAKE
THIS PERMANENT CHANGE OF CITIES
OPTIONS TO DO THAT THIS IS
RECEIVED OVERWHELMING
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT A SUMMONS
FOR TECHNICAL NATURE RESPECT
IRAN. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
DON'T. THANK YOU SO WIENER
MEMBERS ANY DISK OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
BAIT. I BACKER HI FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD HI BY ADAM I COURTESY
HI DOLLY GOD I TORONTO I
EXAMINED EYE LASER EYE GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. I HEARD SPURRED I
WEAR SO. HI HER TADO I JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED. HI LLEVA
I THE MOON. THE WIRE I
MELINDA'S I MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF THE- I CAN
HI FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS. I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
ALL RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL HI. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSA MEMBERS. DALLY
BLUEMOUNTAIN. STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO AMENDMENT
THE SYSTEM LIMITS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM FORTY THREE. BUT
SENATOR WEST SO. SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. SENATE BILL FOUR
SIXTEEN BY SENATOR WEST SO AN
ACT RELATING TO CORRECTIONS.
CENTER WESTON THANK YOU MEMBERS
ARE VERY PROUD TO PRESENT FOR
SIXTEEN WHICH IS AN
INCARCERATED STUDENTS BILL OF
RIGHTS- IN. THIS BILL WOULD
ENSURE INCARCERATIONS HAVE
ACCESS TO FACE TO FACE COLLEGE
INSTRUCTION ONLY PROVIDED BY
QUALIFIED REGIONALLY ACCREDITED
NONPROFIT HIGHER EDUCATION
PROVIDERS THIS IS OUR SIMPLE
YOUR CRITICAL MOVE THAT WILL
RESULT IN POSITIVE LONG TERM
EFFECTS IN A PRISON AND PAROLE
THE POPULATION. THE AMENDMENTS
IN THE ASSEMBLY MAKE THIS A
COSTUME FOR BILL AS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SAID IT WAS SO-
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ACTIONS I FACE HI
BECKER I FOR JUST. FIVE
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
PROTESTING I DOLLY. DOG HI DRAW
SO I EGGMAN EYE GLAZER AIKENS
ALL AS HIGH GROWTH. HI HERZBERG
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO I JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I LABOR I
THE MON. MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S
FIVE MIN I NEWMAN I NELSON. I A
TELEPHONE HI PAM I FORTINO FIVE
ROCK. HI RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG ALL RIGHT HI
KELSEY HI WINNER. I WILL HI
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO A
SIMILAR AMENDMENTS ARE
CONURRED IN MEMBERS WERE GOING
ON TO FILE AND I'M FORTY FOUR
SENATOR LAYERED SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FOUR
SIXTEEN. SENATE BILL FOUR FORTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR LAYERED AN ACT
RELATING TO CIVIL ACTIONS
CENTER ALERT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT OF THIS BILLS
BACK ON AND CURRENT CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY MOVED MANY OPPONENTS
TO NEUTRAL INCLUDING SEJAK
CALCHAMBER CALIFORNIA DEFENSE
COUNSEL AMERICANS PHYSICIANS
GROUPS AND PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION JUST TO NAME A FEW.
THOSE AMENDMENTS PUT A TIGHT
FOR YOUR SUNSET ON THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
TO CONDUCT A REPORT ON THE
BILL'S IMPACT AND COVERS CASES
THAT WERE GRANTED PREFERENCE
BEFORE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THIS MORNING
NARROWED VERSION A PASS THE
ASSEMBLY YESTERDAY WITH FORTY
NINE VOTES I WOULD ASK YOUR
HIGH VOTE TO CONFER CONCURRED
IN THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SIR LET MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
AND I'M FORTY FOUR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA FIVE
ADKINS FIVE BABIES. BECKER I
FOR JUST NO BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI CORTESE HI DOLLY. GOD I
TORONTO HI ADNAN HI PLEASE- I
COULD TOLERATE I GROSS. NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO.
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA HI THE MON MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S. NO MAN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A CHOKE NO PAN.
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH I RUBIO
HI SKINNER I STERN I'M BURKE HI
I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL
NOW. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES NO. DALLY HER
TADO. LIVE MON. PAN STERN.
HIGHS TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS EIGHT
A SIMILAR AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MEMBERS MOVING THE
FILE AND I'M FORTY FIVE WE HAVE
SENATOR EGGMAN. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FOUR
SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR ADMIN AN
ACT RELATING TO MENTAL HEALTH
CENTER ADMIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT SP FOUR SIXTY
FIVE IS BACKING ASSEMBLY FOR
CONCURRENCE DEALING WITH MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS FOR YOUR ITEM.
THANK YOU CENTER ADMIN
EXCELLENT CONCURRENT SPEECH
MEMBERS WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL THIS ITEM
QUALIFIES UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE
ITEM FORTY FIVE. SEEING NO
OBJECTION HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
KNOWS ZERO A SIMILAR AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING ON TO
FILE AND I'M FORTY SIX SENATOR
WIENER'S SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR WIENER AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING SERLING
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SP FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE IT EXPANDS HOUSING
DATA COLLECTION MOMENTS AND-
ASSEMBLY WORKSHOP DURING A
TECHNICAL IN NATURE I ASKED FOR
AND I WILL THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER THIS ALSO QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NO OBJECTION HIGHS
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO A
SIMILAR AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND MOVING ON TO FILE
I'M FORTY SEVEN. CENTER BECKER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE OH THREE BY SENATOR
BACKER AN ACT RELATING TO
VOTING. CENTER BACKER. THANK
YOU- THIS IS FIVE OH THREE BACK
IN THE SAND WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE SECTOR STATE COUNTY
CLERKS AND OTHERS THE MEDICINE
YOU SIMPLY PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DUTIES FOR THE SECRETARY OF
STATE WHEN EVALUATING THE
SIGNATURE VERIFICATION PROCESS.
ANIMATED SOCIAL CHANGES THE
SIGNAL CHANNEL SIX THE
SIGNATURE VERIFICATION PROCESS
FOR VOTERS WHO EITHER MISSING
SIGNATURE OVER NON COMPARING
SIGNATURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU
SIR MALCOLM MEMBERS RUN FILE
ITEM FORTY SEVEN IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ACTIONS HI BABES NO BACKER I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD. I COME BY
ADAM I PROTECTING HI DOLLY DOT.
COM I DRAW SO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I CONSOLIDATE HI GROSS. NO
HERTZBERG. I WAS SO. I HER TADO.
I JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED.
I LLEVA. I THE MON MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MEN HI I. NEWMAN I
NELSON NO A CHOKE NO PAN HI
FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS I RUBIO
I'D SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I
WAKE COUNTY I WINNER. I WILL
NOW. SIZE TWENTY NINE KNOWS
EIGHT IS SIMPLY MADE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO GO TO ITEM FORTY EIGHT
FOLLOWED BY FIFTY TWO AND FIFTY
THREE. FILE AND I'M FORTY EIGHT
IS SENATOR SKINNER. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ AT ABOUT FIVE
TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR SKINNER
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CENTERS CAN. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP FIVE
TWENTY FOUR BACK AND CONCURRENT
SPITTLE HELPS PROTECT PATIENT
CHOICE BY ALLOWING EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US TO CHOOSE THE
PHARMACY EVER CHOOSING THAT'S
WITHIN NETWORK AND HELP LIMIT
PATIENT STEERING. WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I
ACTON'S. I BASE. BACKER I
PORCHES HI BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI PROTESTING HI DALLY.
DOT HI THERE ALSO I EGGMAN HI
LASER. HI GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH
NO HERZBERG I WAS SO. I HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LISA I LIVE ALONE
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON HI A TOTAL OF A-
I CAN I FORCING TINO HI ROB. I
RUBIO I SKINNER FIVE STERNE
AMBERG ALL RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI
I WINNER. I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE UPSET MEMBERS. BATES BALLY
THE MON MELINDA'S STERN. GROVE
NO DOUBT I'D. HIGHS THIRTY FIVE
NO ZERO IS SIMPLY MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY TWO. SENATOR MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIX FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR
MAN AN ACT RELATING TO CHILD
CUSTODY CENTERMAN THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- THIS BILL DEALS
WITH- CHILD SAFETY CREATING NEW
PROTECTIONS RELATED TO
VISITATION AS WELL AS- CHILD
CUSTODY IN CONTESTED CUSTODY
BATTLES ARE TRIED TESTIMONY AND
HIS INTENSITY CUSTODY BATTLES
THE MINUTES MAKING ASSEMBLY
WERE TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING IN
NATURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU SERMON
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. FILE IN
FIFTY TWO QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NO OBJECTION HIGHS
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS IS ZERO
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING OUT OF AN
FIFTY. SENATOR SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SEVENTY SIX
BY SENATOR GONZALES AN ACT
RELATING TO WATER CENTER
CONSOLES THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS TO
SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX CLARIFIED
ENFORCEMENT FINES AND
DEFINITIONS THE BILL AND
ALLOWED FOR TIMELY AND ISSUANCE
OF NOTIFICATION LEVELS OR
DECLARATIONS. OF A CONFIRMED
DETECTION BY THE STATE WATER
BOARD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
PRIVATE. INTERVIEWS ALSO ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ASKINS I FACE NO
BACKER. I PORCHES NO BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM HI CORTEZ HE- I
DALLY DODD. I TORONTO HI AIKMAN
I GLAZER ICONS ALL AS I GROW NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I- TIDO HI
JONES NOPE CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LIVE ON I LIVE ALONE. MCGUIRE
I MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN NO A CHILD BOTH NO PAN
FIVE PERSONS YOU KNOW I. ROSS I
REVIEW I SKINNER. I STERN
AMBERG I Y. CASKEY I WINNER I
WILL KNOW. SIZE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS EIGHT ASSUME LIMITSARE
CONCURRED IN MEMBERS REMOVING
THE FILE AND I'M FIFTY FIVE
WHICH WILL BE FOLLOWED BY FIFTY
SIX AND FIFTY SEVEN FILE IN
FIFTY FIVE IS SENATOR RALPH.
I'M SORRY I'M SORRY WE DID
SEND- BERRY DID THAT WE DID
THAT FIRST CENTER OFF YOU'RE
ALL DONE. ELEVEN FIFTY SIX IS
SENATOR MCCASKEY AND HE IS
READY SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL EIGHT OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI AN ACT
RELATING TO CIVIL RIGHTS CENTER
KELSEY. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS MADE TWO
CHANGES WHAT FIRST WAS TO
REMOVE THE ABILITY FOR A D. F.
E. H. TO HANDLE THEIR OWN
APPEALS OF BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO DO A RISK THEY CAN STILL
FILE A PILL AND THE SECOND WAS
TO REMOVE WHERE YOU CAN FILE A
COMPLAINT IT WAS WHERE THE
OFFICE IS LOCATED WHERE THEY
HAVE STAFF IN SINCE BLACK
PEOPLE WORKING FROM HOME WE
THOUGHT THAT THERE WERE THE
STAFF WERE WERE SEND WILLING SO
THAT WAS REMOVED- ENERGY.
CONCURRENCE THANK YOU SIR MY
CASTING MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON FILE AND I'M FIFTY
SIX. SEEING NONE THIS ALSO
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NO OBJECTION.
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS IS
ZERO A SIMILAR MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NEXT WE HAVE FILE
AND FIFTY SEVEN WAS SENATOR
GLAZIER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY FOUR BY
SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTIONS IN DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE UP SIGNIFICANTLY.
SURVEYS THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS DUE TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE
RELEASE OF CENSUS DATA WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED THE
CYCLE. WHICH LED THE STATE
SUPREME COURT TO MOVE BACK THE
DEADLINE FOR STATE
CONGRESSIONAL REDISTRICTING BY
SEVERAL MONTHS. HOWEVER THIS
EXTENSION HAS CREATED CONFLICTS
WITH THE REMAINING ELECTION
CALENDAR LEADING UP THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO PRIMARY. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS TO SP FIVE NINETY
FOUR MAKES A NUMBER OF
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS THE
CANDIDATE FILING DEADLINES FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO PRIMARY.
AND RELATED ADMINISTRATIVE
CHANGES TO ALIGN THEM WITH THIS
LATER REDISTRICTING DEADLINE.
AND TO PROVIDE ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS WITH NECESSARY TIME
TO RE PRECINCT. FIVE NINETY
FOUR ALSO MAKES A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT CLARIFICATIONS AND
CHANGES TO THE LOCAL
REDISTRICTING PROCESS. TO GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND TIME FOR
REDISTRICTING WHILE ACCOUNTING
FOR THE ADMINISTRATIVE NEEDS OF
ELECTION OFFICIALS THE BILL
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONAUT ABOUT.
THANK YOU CENTER CLOSER MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
THIS BILL IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION SEEING AND
HEARING MAN ISERIES SEVEN NO
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM
FORTY NINE AND FIFTY. SENATOR
JONES. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR JONES AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALING ARTS CENTER JONES
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY FOUR
UPDATES THE DENTAL HYGIENE
PRACTICE ACT. THAT'S IMPLEMENTS
REMOVED THE APPOINTMENT SECTION
OF THE BILL AND AT THE REQUEST
OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I
ASKED FOR YOUR I. BOATS IN
CONCURRENCE THE CENTER JONES
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE THIS IS ALSO A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION. BEING IN
HER NANA'S THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THIS SOME WOMEN MINTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FIFTY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR JONES AN ACT
RELATING TO MENTAL HEALTH.
CENTER JONES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATE BILL FIVE
SEVENTY RECURS REQUIRES
CONSERVATORSHIP PROCEEDINGS
UNDER THE LAND GERMAN PETRA
SHORT ACT. TO BE HELD IN CLOSED
COURT AND LAST THE SUBJECT OF
THE PETITION REQUESTS TO BE
PUBLIC. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
LOWER THE FISCAL ESTIMATE BY
CLARIFYING THAT ONLY
PROCEEDINGS WHICH DISCLOSE
CONFIDENTIAL CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION ARE REQUIRED TO BE
HELD IN CLOSED COURT I ASKED
YOU I VOTE IN CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE THIS IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NO. ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. SENATORS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NOW TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING. WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT. THEN ONE NINETY SEVEN
ONE HUNDRED AND A COUPLE MORE
AFTER THAT WE'LL START WITH
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH
IS CENTER WEST SO. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTINO THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVIN AND ACT RELATING TO
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY BARRACKS
EXPECT MEDIALLY. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND COLLEAGUES SAYS BE
FORTINO THREE. AUTHORIZES THE
GOVERNOR TO DECLARE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY OR LOCAL EMERGENCY
DUE TO- THE ENERGY STATION
EVENT BY INCLUDING THESE EVENTS
WITHIN THE DEFINITION OF
CONDITIONS THAT WARRANT A STATE
EMERGENCY DECLARATION. THIS
BILL IS DOUBLE JOINED WITH THIS
B. FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR DOT
WHICH WOULD ACCOMPLISH THE SAME
GOAL. OF THIS BILL FOR LOCAL
EMERGENCY DECLARATION-
THIRTEEN- THE ENERGY STATION
APPEARS TO BE A SERVANT FOR THE
DEFINITION OF CONDITIONS THAT-WERE IN A STATE OF EMERGENCY
DECLARATION WILL HELP THE SAME.
IT WILL HELP THE STATE QUICKLY
ADDRESS HARMFUL IMPACTS ON
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND PUBLIC
SAFETY CAUSED BY ONE OF THESE
EVENTS HAS FOR A NEIGHBOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR WAS SO
MEMBERS RUN ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS HI BABES. BACKER I
PORCHES. BRADFORD. BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ C. I. DALLY GOD. TORONTO
I EGGMAN I GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE
I DROVE NO HURTS BERG I WENT SO.
HI HER TADO I JONES NO CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA I LIVE
ALONE THE CHOIR. I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN. NIELSEN I-
TELEVOTE. NO PAN I FOURTEEN TO
NO. HI RALPH I REVIEW FIVE
SKINNER. STERN NUMBER I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FAITH NO PORGES NO BRADFORD.
DALLY DODD I. MON MELINDA'S
NEWMAN. SCANNER. HI STERN.
NIELSEN I DON'T KNOW RIGHT
BRADFORD HI. MELINDA'S NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLY LIVE MON NEWMAN STERN.
HIGHS TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT
ON THE URGENCY EYES TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT ON THE
MEASURE THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN. SENATOR
ALAN SECRETARY PLEASE RE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO PRODUCT SAFETY
CENTER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES- THIS BILL. I
PROTECTS CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENCE
IN THE ENVIRONMENT BY REDUCING
HUMAN EXPOSURE TO AN
ENVIRONMENTAL CONTAMINATION
FROM. T. FOSS AND OTHER
HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS. WE'VE
DISCUSSED THIS ON THE FLOOR
THERE- BASICALLY NINE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUAL FOREVER CHEMICALS
THAT HAVE BEEN LINKED TO A
MYRIAD OF HEALTH ISSUES LIKE
CANCERS AND HORMONE DISRUPTION.
KIDNEY LIVER DAMAGE AND MORE.
AND WE NOW. KNOW THAT THAT P.
FIVE HAS BEEN DETECTED IN THE
BLOOD OF OVER 98% OF AMERICANS.
SO YOU'LL RECALL THAT LAST YEAR
WE PASSED LEGISLATION TO THESE
FOREVER CHEMICALS OUT OF
FIREFIGHTING FOAM- THAT WAS A
GREAT BPARTISAN EFFORT- BUT
THESE DANGEROUS CHEMICALS ARE
ALSO FREQUENTLY FOUND OUR TAKE
OUT FOOD CONTAINERS AND
COOKWARE AND FROM THERE THEY
CAN THEN LEACH INTO FOODS. THAT
WE EAT. INDIVIDUAL FOOD
COMPANIES LIKE MCDONALD'S
WENDY'S WHOLE FOODS CHIPOTLE-
OTHER STATES LIKE NEW YORK HAVE
ALREADY PROACTIVELY BEEN
PHASING OUT OR BANNING P. FILES
FROM PAPER BASED FOOD PACKAGING
IN A RECENT REPORT. FOUND THAT
NEARLY 80% OF NONSTICK PANS AND
20% A BIG. WHERE TESSA
CONTAMINATED. SITE TESTING- THE
BIG WE HAVE A COATING IS MADE
FROM P. FAST. SO THIS BILL.
BANS THE USE OF P. FAST IN
PLANT BASED FOOD PACKAGING BY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. IT
REQUIRES COOKWARE MANUFACTURERS
TO DISCLOSE THE USE OF P. FIVE
ANOTHER CAT HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS
FROM THE GSES CANDIDATE
CHEMICAL LISTING THEIR
PRODUCTS. ONLINE BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND THEN ON THE
PACKAGING WE TWENTY FOUR IT
PROHIBITS MISLEADING MARKETING
CLAIMS ON COOKWARE CLAIMED.
CLAIMING TO BE FREE OF A
SPECIFIC HAZARDOUS CHEMICAL
ANOTHER SIMILAR CHEMICALS ARE
PRESENT. SO WITH THAT RESPECT
YESTERDAY BUT I JUST WANT TO
MENTION BY THE WAY THAT- THE
AUTHOR WAS VERY HARD TO STRIKE
A DEAL WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
REMOVED. LITERALLY EVERY EVERY
SINGLE OPPOSITION GROUP EXCEPT
FOR ONE THAT- HI I DON'T KNOW
THE STORY BEHIND THIS
PARTICULAR ONE BUT- THIS IS THE
THIS IS THE PRODUCT OF A OF A
GRAND COMPROMISE IT MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE- AND I RESPECT
YESTERDAY ABOUT. THANK YOU SIR
ALAN MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. CENTER
MELINDA'S.
SEVERAL ANALYSTS I
THINK MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS-
WHEN THIS BILL CAME BEFORE OUR
COMMITTEE I VOTED AGAINST IT
SINCE THEN IT HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED ON THE
AUTHOR DIDN'T WORK VERY HARD
WITH THE OPPOSITION- AND AT
THIS POINT I AM SUPPORTIVE OF
THE BILL BECAUSE I WOULD HAVE
TO AGREE WITH THE PREMISE OF
THE BILL THAT WE DO HAVE TO GET
THESE DANGEROUS CHEMICALS OUT
OF THE PRODUCTS THAT. WE SERVE
OUR FOOD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR MELINDA'S ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE AT
A NINETY SEVEN. ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA ATKINS I
BASE I BACKER HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTESE I DALI DODD. HI THERE
AWESOME HI ADNAN EYE LASER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROWTH. I HURTS
BERG I WAS SO HYPER TANTO HI
JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I
LLEVA I THE MOON WIRE. HI
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. I WILL GO. PAN HI
FORTINO. I BROUGHT HI RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN I'M BERG ALL
RIGHT HI MIKE HOW SKI I WINNER
I WILL. HI PLEASE CALL THE
UPSET MEMBERS. ARCHULETA I.
DALLY JONES. LIMO ON A TROUBLED
I STERN. SIZE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO- LIFTED
LET THE CALL ON THE MISSING
VOTES ON THE FEW ITEMS THAT WE
HAVE WE'RE GONNA START WITH
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN ON THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS MEMBERS
WERE LIFTING THE CALL SO IF YOU
MISS THE VOTES EARLIER NOW IS
YOUR CHANCE TO. GET ON THE ROLE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FAITH PORGES. DALLY ADMIN I
GROVE. JONES CAN LONGER I
MELINDA'S NIELSEN A SHOW OF
BOTH. STERN. HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS
ONE GOVERNOR APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON A FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BAYTEX FOR JUST BALLY
AIKMAN I ROVE. JONES CAN LONGER.
MELINDA'S MAN I NIELSEN A
TROUBLED SKINNER. I TURN. SIZE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS ONE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON TO- FILE
ITEM FIFTY FIVE AS PO THREE
CENTER ROUGH SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. VALLEY ADMIN HI
GLAZER I GROVE. I. CAN LONGER I.
LIMONIUM MELINDA'S STERN THE-
SIZE THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ONE
ESTIMATES ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
ONE SP SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
SENATOR BRADFORD'S SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DALLY CAN
LONGER I LIMONIUM STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO OR SIMPLY%
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FIVE MOVING TO FILE AN M.
TWENTY FOUR S. B. TWENTY THREE
SENATOR RUBIO SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. DALLY KAMMERER. I STERN.
SIZE THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM TWENTY
SIX S. B. FORTY FOUR SENATOR
ALAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL VALLEY GROSS. JONES CAN
LONGER I THE MON MELINDA'S
NIELSEN STERN WELK. HIGHS
THIRTY TWO KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING ON A FILE ITEM TWENTY
NINE SP ONE TEN SENATOR
WIENER'S SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. DALLY CAMCORDER I
STERN. SIZE THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
ZERO ESTIMATES ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY S. B. TWO
FORTY FOUR CINDER ARCH ALETTA
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DALLY CAN LONGER I EARN. SIZE
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO
ESTIMATES ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
AND I'M THIRTY ONE S. B. THREE
OH THREE SENATOR BORJA
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DALLY ADMIN I CAN LONGER I
STERN HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO A SIMILAR AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING ON A FILE
AND I'M THIRTY THREE S. B.
THREE SIXTY NINE SENATOR PAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DALLY CAN LONGER I STERN. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO A SIMILAR
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE SP FOUR
FORTY SIX INTERGRADES OR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SALLY CAN LONGER I EARN FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO A SIMILAR
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN SP SIX
TWENTY NINE SENATOR ROTH
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DALLY CAN LONGER. I STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO A
SIM LIMITS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE SP TWENTY
SEVEN SENATORS SKINNER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DALLY I AM LONGER I STERN HIGHS
THIRTY FOUR KNOWS FOR ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM FORTY S. B. TWO TWO
FOUR SENATOR PORTENT TINO
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
TALLY CAN LONGER. I STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO
ESTIMATES ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS THIS IS THE FINAL ON
CALL ITEM FILE ITEM FORTY ONE
S. B. TWO SIXTY FOUR SENATOR
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. DALLY HER TADO. CAN
LONGER I ROTH. STERN. SIZE
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT A
SIMILAR AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO. TRYING TO MOVE
TO CONSENT. IS THERE ANY MEMBER
THAT WISHES TO PULL AN ITEM OFF
OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATOR RUBIO. MR PRESIDENT AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE PULL FILE ITEM. TWO SIX
NINE EIGHTY THREE ONE SIX FROM
CONCEPT FOR THE PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO DOES WILL NOTE.
SENATOR TARO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR ASKS THAT WE MOVE A. B.
THREE ONE SEVEN FILE ITEM TWO
SEVEN ZERO FROM THE SPECIAL
CONCERT CALENDARTO THIRD
READING FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU SARAH
TODD- SENATOR BECKER. YES I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RETURN SENATE BILL FIVE OR FOUR
TO THE SIMPLY FOR FURTHER
ACTION. THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER
THE DECIBEL NOTE. CENTER
GLAZIER I SAW YOU STANDING UP
THERE IN THE BACK DID YOU WANT
TO BE RECOGNIZED. OKAY JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE. THANK YOU
CENTER GEATER CENTERS BERG.
JUST IN THE FIELD THERE ALL
RIGHT I THINK FOR ALL I'M SORRY
ONE MORE CENTER ADMIN. B. SEVEN
NINETEEN FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
EIGHT ISN'T LIKE A COLLECTIVE
COMMITTEE TO THE INACTIVE FILE
THANK YOU CENTER ADMIN. SINCE
GETTING. MEMBERS BY MOVE THE
ADOPTION OF AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
FOR. THE FOLLOWING MEASURES
THAT WILL CROSS THE DESK ON
SATURDAY. OH SORRY PROLOGIS
OKAY. YES MA'AM CENTER ADMIN
YOUR MICROPHONE BROKE UP A
LITTLE BIT WHILE YOU WERE
PRESENTING YOUR YOUR CONSENT
ITEM TO PULL CAN YOU RESTATE
THAT FOR US PLEASE. EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETEEN PLEASE TO THE
INACTIVE FILE THANK YOU. YEAH.
MEMBERS JUST AS A REMINDER ON
THE CONSENT COUNTER AT THIS
POINT TIMER ONLY PULLING ITEMS
OFF OF CONSENT IF YOU HAVE AN
ITEM TO PULL OFF CONSENT PLEASE
INDICATE. THAT YOU NEED TO
SPEAK. OKAY I THINK WE'RE GOOD
TO GO. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SEVENTY TO A 1-002-232-4022.
SEVENTY SEVEN TO EIGHTY SEVEN
TO NINETY THREE THREE FORTY
THREE SEVENTY ALLY HAS BEEN
READY. AND MORE HELLO I'M SORRY
WE GOTTA TAKE THE WHOLE ALL THE
I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT. PLEASE
CONTINUE. 340-375-4174
1-843-453-4614. SEVENTY TWO
FIVE ELEVEN FIVE FOURTEEN FIVE
TWENTY THREE FIVE SEVENTY SIX
FIVE SEVENTY NINE FIVE NINETY
TWO FIVE NINE NINE. SIX OH FOUR
SIX TWENTY FIVE. 1-266-769-2740
FOUR SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN SIXTY
FOUR. SEVEN EIGHTY ONE SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT FORTY THREE NINE
FORTY FIVE NINE FIFTY EIGHT TEN
SEVENTY TEN EIGHTY TWO.
311-270-1240 712-501-3407
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN FIFTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT AND ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ANY
OBJECTION. TO UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NONE HIGHS THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
AND I. OKAY MEMBERS NOW WE'RE
GONNA GO TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. AND ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED IN OUR MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. CENTERS FOR. AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILL
TO THE INACTIVE FILE FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY SIX FILE NUMBER
SIXTY SIX A. B. THREE FIFTY ONE
THE AUTHORS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SERRA FIRST
SERRA WHAT'S SO. YES THANK YOU
IT HAS COME TO MY ATTENTION
THAT THERE WERE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE NOT ADDED TO AB FORTINO
THREE WE JUST VOTED TO APPROVE
IT. FELT LIKE TO ASK THAT WE
CONSIDER. TO BE FORTINO THREE
FIVE TWO APARTMENTS AT FORTINO
3% LESSER WAS ASKING FOR
RECONSIDERATION IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. TO RECONSIDERING AB
FORTINO THREE SEEING NONE HIGHS
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED. ANY
OTHER MEMBERS UNDER. SAN ROMAN.
TO MAKE IT ABSOLUTELY CLEAR I
DO REQUEST THAT WE MOVE UP BY
L. ITEM OR ONE FIFTY EIGHT
WHICH IS A B. SEVEN NINETEEN
THE ASSEMBLY BILL ON
AGRICULTURE TO THE INACTIVE FOR.
THANK YOU SIR I WENT. RIGHT SIR
BACKER TO JEWISH TO RECOGNIZE.
OKAY THE CENTRE SKINNER. IT WAS
THE RIGHT- AMENDED MOTION THANK
YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS I MOVE
THE ADOPTION OF AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS FOR THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES I WAS READING THE
MOMENT THAT CROSS THE DESK ON
SATURDAY SUNDAY AND MONDAY
SEPTEMBER FOURTH FIFTH AND
SIXTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THESE
MEASURES ARE. A. B.
ONE FIFTY
FOUR ONE FIFTY FIVE ONE SIXTY
TO ONE SIXTY THREE ONE SIXTY
FIVE ONE SIXTY SIX ONE SIXTY
SEVEN ONE SIXTY EIGHT ONE SIXTY
NINE ONE SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY
ONE ONE SEVENTY TWO. ONE
SEVENTY THREE ONE SEVENTY FOUR
ONE SEVENTY FIVE ONE SEVENTY
SIX. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT AND ONE SEVENTY
NINE. THESE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
ADOPTED PUBLISHED AND THE
MEASURES RETURNED TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER SENATOR NELSON I OBJECT
AND ASK FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE
THESE ARE AMENDMENTS OVER THE
WEEKEND OF THE BUDGET AND- THAT
SHE'S. TIRED YOUR NOBLE. THANK
YOU SIR NIELSEN MEMBERS THERE'S
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR SENATOR
SKINNER IS ASKING FOR AN I.
VOTE CENTER NIELSEN IS ASKING
FOR NO NO VOTE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA FIVE ADKINS. EIGHT
NOPE BACKER. I PORCHES KNOW
BRADFORD. COLORADO I
POTENTIALLY I DALLEY DIED. I
DRAW SO I EXAMINED EYE LASER
EYE GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
I JONES NO CAMCORDER I LAYERED
I LABOR. I THE MOON. REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NOPE MEN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. NO I TRIED BOTH NO CAN
I PRESENT YOU KNOW I. ROSS. I
REVIEW I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
ALL RIGHT HI FI CASKEY FIVE
WINNER. I WILL KNOW SIZE TWENTY
SEVEN KNOWS EIGHT MOTION
CARRIES THE SCHOOL NOTE THE
MOTION. CENTRE BACK OR COMING
BACK TO YOU. NOW IS THE PERFECT
TIME I'VE WITH RED RICE REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RETURN
SENATE BILL FIVE OF FOURTEEN
SIMPLY FOR FURTHER ACTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR BECKER DESK
WILL NOTE. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION. FOR MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR GLACIER
WHAT. MEMBERS MEMBERS I.
MEMBERS I RISE I RISE TO WISH I
RISE. MEMBER CENTER GLAZIER HAS
BEEN PROPERLY RECOGNIZED FOR
HIS NOTICE THAT'S A PLEASE GIVE
DUE. RESPECT TO OUR COLLEAGUE.
EVEN THOUGH HE IS VIOLATING THE
DRESS CODE. SENATOR GLAZIER I
HAVE A COAT AND TIE ON MEMBERS
I RISE- SIMPLY TO WISH MY
COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE FLOOR
AND THEIR FRIENDS WHO BLEED
DODGER BLUE THE BEST OF LUCK.
IN A SERIES THAT BEGINS THIS
WEEKEND AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE
GIANTS AND THE DODGERS ARE TIED
FOR THE BEST RECORD IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL WHAT AN
ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR BOTH TEAMS.
THOUGH THEY HAVE PLAYED EACH
OTHER SIXTEEN TIMES THIS YEAR.
AND THE RECORD STANDS IS EIGHT
FOR THE DODGERS AND EIGHT FOR
THE GIANTS. WHAT'S EVEN MORE
SURPRISING THEY BOTH HAVE
SCORED THE EXACT SAME NUMBER OF
RUN SIXTY EIGHT RUNS THIS YEAR
AS THEY GO INTO THEIR THREE
GAME SERIES THAT BEGINS
TONIGHT. SO I WANTED TO SAY TO
MY FRIENDS- YOU HAVE THE ONE OF
THE BEST TEAMS IN BASEBALL I
INCREDIBLE FRANCHISE THE
GREATEST TALENT ON THE FIELD
AND WE IT IN SAN FRANCISCO ARE
HAPPY TO HOST YOU TODAY AND
THIS WEEKEND TO ENJOY THE FINE
PLAY THAT YOU BRING. TO THE
FIELD AND AT THE END TO ALL OF
US WERE EXCITED ABOUT THE
SERIES SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR- SENSITIVITY AND
ATTENTION- THIS AFTERNOON. AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY. THE LA.
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER. THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZER SENATOR
DURAZO. WORLD CHAMPION DODGERS.
SIXTY LOCATED IN MY DISTRICT
I'M SO PROUD. HELLO YES LEADS
THE LEAGUE IN WINS WALKER
BUEHLER LEADS THE LEAGUE IN
EARNED RUN AVERAGE TRADE TURNER
LEADS THE LEAGUE IN BATTLE
BATTING- AND HITS SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE WORLD
CHAMPION DODGERS. BUT THEY ARE
NOT ONLY EXCELLENCE ON THE
FIELD THEY ARE CHAMPS OFF THE
FIELD. THEY SET UP THE LARGEST
VOTING SITES IN THIS STATE THE
LARGEST COVERT TESTING SITES
FOOD DISTRIBUTION THEY WERE
NAMED THE ESPN TWENTY TWIN THE
HUMANITARIAN TEAM OF THE YEAR
BECAUSE OF THEIR WORK ON SOCIAL
JUSTICE HOMELESSNESS. AND US
SUPPORT FOR LOCAL SCHOOLS NOW
THAT'S WHAT I CALLED CHAMPS.
AND SO GOOD LUCK JOANNE'S. WE
WILL BE LED BY DAVE ROBERTS ONE
OF ONLY TWO BLACK MANAGERS IN
THE LEAGUE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ANOTHER WORLD CHAMPION TIME FOR
A DODGER BASEBALL. THANK YOU
SENATOR DRAWS US SENATOR MEN. I
JUST FEEL COMPELLED TO SPEAK UP
ON BEHALF OF OUR HOMETOWN
ORANGE COUNTY LOS ANGELES
ANGELS WHICH- HAVE NOWHERE
CLOSE TO THE BEST RECORD IN
BASEBALL BUT HAVE SOMEHOW FOR
YEARS DESPITE HAVING THE BEST
PLAYER IN BASEBALL MIKE TROUT I
HAVE BEEN MEDIOCRE AND THEN
TOPPED THAT OFF BY ACQUIRING.
THE I CALL YOU WITH THE SECOND
BEST PLAYER IN BASEBALL SHOHEI
OHTANI THE FIRST TWO WAY PLAYER
EVER NAMED TO THE ALL STAR GAME
WE HAVE THE TWO MOST EXCITING
PLAYERS IN BASEBALL AND YET WE
SIT BELOW FIVE HUNDRED SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS SERIES I
HOPE THE ANGELS CAN COME AROUND
ONE OF THESE DAYS AND- THAT
THEY- LOOK FOR TWO. THANK YOU.
CENTER MAN WE'RE ONLY
DISCUSSING- LEADING- RECORD
BASEBALL TEAMS TODAY. AND AS A-
AS A RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY ON VERY. TORN BETWEEN
THE DODGERS AND THE GIANTS. I'M
GONNA ROOT FOR THE DODGERS TO
WIN ONE GAME SO I DON'T HAVE TO
SEE SENATOR DODD WALKING WITH
HIS BROOM AGAIN AND TRY TO
SWEEP THE FLOOR. OF THE SENATE
AS HE DID IN THE ASSEMBLY A
COUPLE YEARS AGO. SO WITH THAT
I THINK WE'RE MOVING ON TO- IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR BATES THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL FIVE PM AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTIN WILL BE
PLACED WE WILL REGROUP WE WILL
RECONVENE TUESDAY AT NOON.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
FIVE PM AT WHICH TIME THE
GERMAN MOTION WILL BE PLACED.
WE WILL RECONVENE TUESDAY AT
NOON LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
THE SENATE WE ARE ADJOURNED
PLEASE HAVE A- FOR A RECESS OF
FIVE PLEASE HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND
IN JOY AND CELEBRATE LABOR DAY
APPROPRIATELY WE'LL SEE YOU ON
TUESDAY.